all right so I'm looking at the Pimsleur
website right now this is the this is
the page for Pimsleur French and this
looks really good I think I'm going to
buy this so let's check the price what's
that
well that here's the price in pesos I
wonder how much it is in dollars
wait that's dollars hello folks this is
Paul how you doing today huh I've
decided to make this video to give you a
review about a language program called
Pimsleur Pimsleur French is the one I
wanted to focus on I've done some other
Pimsleur courses i I've done I did one
level of Arabic right now I'm using
Tagalog I did keep one level of Hebrew
once but the one that I've gone through
the most is French I've did four levels
of French there are five levels now that
I've done four of them so I thought I'm
in the best position to keep that one in
mind and focus on that one
so Pimsleur right there are five levels
it's quite good I like it but I think
it's quite expensive and that seems to
be one of the common complaints is just
the price like it's a it's a good
quality program to learn the basic
skills of a language but it's just
really expensive so if you buy CDs like
levels one to five would be like 150 CDs
because there's 30 CDs per level if you
bought them all on CD that would be I
think about $1,200 u.s. so quite a lot
of money right you can get them in
digital format in mp3 for about $550 I
believe is the price so less than half
price for digital format so you can get
that discount and I don't recommend
buying CDs why would you buy the CDs in
2015 when you can just get the mp3
downloads for less than half the price
so do that or if your friend or someone
happens to have the CDs maybe you can
borrow them if you feel epicly okay with
that and if you're not worried about
simon and schuster coming to hunt you
down then borrow them I don't know find
a way but it's good but it's too
expensive that's kind of the main thing
I wanted to start with but let's talk
about what's good I'll give you my kind
of
sandwich format I'll give you the good
than the imperfect and then kind of wind
up with the good and maybe a suggestion
on how to use it
so the good things first one good thing
is just that it's an all audio program
and it really gets you familiar with the
phonology of the language the sounds of
the language I'm big on that I really
think it's important at the beginning
when you learn a language to really get
down the phonology I think that's what
that's what helps you think in that
language is what is really getting the
phonology down that's kind of the access
to the inner core of the language the
culture of the language Pimsleur helps
to do that because you're you're
immersed in the the sounds right from
the beginning and you're not relying on
the visual input you're kind of forced
to listen to the sounds and make sense
of them audibly without having that
visual input of reading so it's really
good for that so that's one thing and it
does it in a way that also drills the
sentence structure so you're not just
like listening and repeating two sounds
or phrases or sentences it's actually
building up piece by piece it's it's
really structured in a way that helps
you to build progressively more
difficult sentences as you go another
good thing about Pimsleur is that it
uses something called graduated
intervals which is one of the features
that it's famous for I guess graduated
intervals means that you learn some
language like vocabulary or phrase or
structure then you review it soon after
after a short interval of time but then
the next time you review it the interval
of time gets a little longer and then
the next time you review it there's a
little bit longer between the reviews so
the amount of time between each each
review each time you are asked to recall
that language gets greater and greater
so that's good for for basically
internalizing it into your long-term
memory the more times that you review
that that language the less frequently
you have to review it that's basically
the point if you're familiar with unki
flashcards they use something as a
similar system to that where these space
repetitions where if you get the card
right then the next time you see it is
after a greater interval if you get the
card wrong or you are
confident about it then you see it after
a shorter interval is something similar
to graduated intervals another good
thing is that thumbs ler gets you just
to repeat things a lot like you're
repeating the same structures in the
same both basic vocabulary over and over
and over and when you're first learning
a language it's important to do that to
repeat things over a lot to get some
automaticity to get things internalized
to the point where you can save them
without really thinking especially for
structures like basic sentence
structures that's good because you get
those structures that come out
automatically and then you can
substitute vocabulary and make new
sentences that you've never made before
so it drills a lot of that kind of thing
it gets you repeating a lot but it does
it in a way that always seems like
you're learning something new okay so
onto some of the things that are
imperfect or things that I need I think
need to be supplemented or whatever um I
don't think that the audio only is
always sufficient there are always some
times in a Pimsleur course where I can't
clearly hear what the speaker is saying
on the CDs I think everyone perceives
sounds a little bit differently and
there are sounds that you might be able
to perceive very easily that I hear them
and I can't quite hear what what they're
saying I just don't know what letters
those would come out to if written down
or I just I can't imagine what the word
is I can't really perceive the sounds
and in those kind of situations they
don't really they don't know which
sounds I'm not perceiving so they don't
clarify it so eh I can't really stick to
the Pimsleur philosophy of only listen
to the CD only use the audio in that
kind of situation so I break their rules
and I reach for my dictionary and look
up a word that sounds like what they're
saying or I'll pause it and I'll try to
find find out what the word is but I
need to use some kind of visual input
and having the visual input in that kind
of situation is really helpful because
if you can't perceive the sound once you
see it then you can perceive it because
you'll be connecting that mysterious
sound with something visual
right so I I don't buy the whole audio
only thing 100% I think it's really good
to have a focus on audio especially in
the beginning and that solves a lot of
the the problems of traditional learning
using just books without a lot of audio
or like
book with just one CD or whatever but I
think it's still good to have some
visual input so I think it's good to do
this to do Pimsleur in conjunction with
other more visual materials another
thing is that you just never quite learn
as much as you think you're going to
learn I think partly that's because
people look at the size of the course
like 150 CDs for five levels or even
just like the first two levels wow
that's 60 CDs if I finish 60 CDs of
French I'm going to have to be fluent
right that's 60 whole CDs of French I'm
going to have to be really really good
after that aren't I
or they look at the price and they say
wow okay it's $1000 for five levels I
that must make me fluent that better
make me fluent so I'm spending a lot of
money on that but it doesn't really work
like that like it gives you a good basis
a good basic understanding and a good
basic anchoring and speaking listening
and interactive skills it gives you a
good basis to build on but it's it's not
going to make you fluent so basically I
think Pimsleur is really good the only
problem I have with it is the price I
just think it's too expensive I know a
lot of work goes into it and they can
charge whatever they want but just a lot
of people can't really afford to buy all
the levels so you know that's the that's
what it is it's the price but it's good
good quality I think it's good for
building up your you're listening and
you're speaking and your oral
communication skills without relying on
the visual too much that solves kind of
some of those problems of traditional
learning we had with just focusing on
written materials too much focusing on
the visual input too much not being able
to translate that into conversations
Pimsleur is kind of one of the ways you
can solve that problem but I don't think
Pimsleur alone is enough I think you
need to supplement it with visual input
even at the same time while you're doing
Pimsleur Pimsleur advises you against
that I don't believe that I think you
should substant with visual materials
use a textbook you know read authentic
materials try to use as much visual
input as you can use other sources not
just the audio
right in on top of that the audio on the
Pimsleur CDs is controlled right it's
controlled practice it's there's a lot
of repeating there's a lot of there's a
lot of question and answer type of type
of structures so it's it's really
limited in what you hear and what you're
expected to produce so you need to have
experience from the beginning in
uncontrolled situations free practice
right that means talk with native
speakers in a context that's not really
laid out that where you're just
conversing and trying to communicate and
figuring out how to say things and you
can do that by getting a teacher like a
tutor on I talkie through Skype you can
take lessons or so if someone in your
town speaks that language and they can
tutor you or help you out you can get a
language partner and do a language
exchange something like that and then
use that as your opportunity to practice
communicating and then when there's a
communication break down or there's like
a language barrier they can help you get
through that by telling you oh in this
situation we say this whatever so you
learn how to deal with those unexpected
natural situations that come up in real
conversations that you won't get on the
Pimsleur CD so you need to supplement
you need the visual input and you also
need that free practice and if you do
though all those things in conjunction
with the Pimsleur then you're going to
come out with a really strong base and
when you're done the courses you'll be
ready to get into some simple
conversations and then build more and
more on top of that so PIMs was good the
price I don't know what to say about it
but try to get your hands on them use
them but supplement it's not the only
thing to use but it's good